Nous sommes en mars 1761, Rousseau a 48 ans.
Un comte hongrois se rend à Paris pour rencontrer
le célèbre philosophe.
Mais qui le reçoit ?
Un homme vêtu d’une vieille robe de chambre.
Et puis cette vieille robe de chambre est
pleine de tâches.
Le comte hongrois, qui appartient à la haute
aristocratie, est choqué par une telle négligence.
Mais les yeux de l’homme dans la vieille
robe de chambre dégueulasse — ces yeux
ont une vivacité extraordinaire.
C’est bien lui.
C’est le philosophe dont tout le monde parle.
Aujourd’hui, ça passerait pour une petite
provocation.
Mais se présenter à un aristocrate avec
autant de familiarité au milieu du XVIIIe
siècle, ça demande du cran.
Rousseau se le permet parce que c’est son
personnage.
Contrairement aux autres grands noms des Lumières,
pour lui, philosophe, ça ne veut pas simplement
dire écrivain.
Pour lui, ça veut aussi dire adopter un mode
de vie particulier, le plus possible conforme
à ses idées.
Et ça, ça le rend fascinant déjà de son
vivant.
Mais ce qui le rend surtout fascinant pour
nous, c’est qu’il est le penseur des Lumières
le plus influent en Occident.
Nous lui devons certaines de nos idées les
plus importantes dans notre vision de la politique,
de la justice sociale, ou encore de l’éducation.
Son influence est si grande que certains voient
en lui le père involontaire des pires idéologies,
en particulier des totalitarismes.
Bertrand Russell, le philosophe anglais qui
a écrit l’histoire de la philosophie occidentale
de référence — Bertrand Russell dit par
exemple : « Hitler est un disciple de Rousseau
».
Ouh.
Mais elles viennent d’où, ces idées si
dangereuses ?
Eh bien de la vie EXCEPTIONNELLE de Rousseau.
Et je ne dis pas « exceptionnelle » pour
vous persuader de regarder la vidéo.
Il y a tellement de choses folles dans sa
vie que j’ai eu beaucoup de mal à sélectionner
10 anecdotes.
J’ai donc ignoré les anecdotes les plus
connues.
Ni Rousseau lui-même, ni vos profs de lycée
ou d’université ne vous ont raconté ce
que vous allez découvrir dans mes 10 anecdotes.
Si vous tenez à la LÉGENDE de Rousseau,
ne regardez pas cette vidéo.
Mais si vous voulez connaître la vérité,
alors écoutez-moi jusqu’au bout.
Nous sommes au début du XVIIIe siècle.
Isaac Rousseau, un horloger suisse, vit dans
un quartier cosmopolite d’Istanbul.
Mais il est un immigré récent.
Il a laissé sa femme, Suzanne, et leur fils,
François Rousseau, à Genève.
Et après six ans passés en Turquie, il décide
de rentrer en Suisse.
Juste après le décès de sa belle-mère.
Tiens tiens…
Isaac reparaît donc à Genève en 1711.
On imagine les retrouvailles avec sa femme
: leur second fils, Jean-Jacques Rousseau,
en est le fruit.
Cette anecdote révèle le caractère du père
de Rousseau.
Or, ce caractère déteindra sur son fils.
Le père transmettra d’abord son humeur
migratoire à son fils.
C’est vrai que les Genevois de l’époque
voyagent beaucoup, en partie à cause des
difficultés économiques
— et Isaac Rousseau, lui, n’a pas peur
d’aller s’installer en Turquie.
Plus tard, il vivra dans différentes villes
en Suisse
(il y refera sa vie, parce que la mère du
philosophe est morte 10 jours après sa naissance).
Jean-Jacques, lui, se déplacera bien plus
que son père.
Après sa fugue à 16 ans, il vivra entre
la France, l’Italie, la Suisse, et même
l’Angleterre.
Il déménagera au gré des opportunités
et de la censure.
Un autre trait de personnalité que le père
transmet à son fils, c’est sa capacité
à essayer de nouvelles choses.
Par exemple, au début de la vingtaine, Isaac
Rousseau arrête l’horlogerie pour devenir
prof de danse.
Mais finalement, il revient à l’horlogerie
un an plus tard.
Jean-Jacques sera bien plus touche-à-tout
que son père.
Il se passionnera pour la musique, le théâtre,
la botanique, et bien sûr la philosophie
et la politique.
Enfin, le père transmettra encore au fils
son sang chaud.
Isaac Rousseau s’emporte facilement.
Il est un peu une tête brûlée.
Ainsi, il fuit Genève pour échapper à des
poursuites judiciaires quand Jean-Jacques
a 10 ans.
Jean-Jacques, lui, ne sera pas violent comme
il semble que son père l’ait été
— mais comme lui, il n’aura jamais peur
du conflit, y compris avec les puissants et
avec les personnes dont il dépend.
C’est même pire : comme son père, Jean-Jacques
monte trop rapidement sur ses grands chevaux.
Il monte au créneau pour un rien.
Il est très susceptible, et il est déterminé
à ne jamais se laisser faire.
Bernardin de Saint-Pierre, l’auteur du fameux
roman romantique Paul et Virginie, était
un ami proche de Rousseau.
Et il prétend que Rousseau lisait ce livre,
les Vies parallèles de Plutarque, à seulement
deux ans et demi !
Bien sûr…
Et puis il savait déjà lire dans le ventre
de sa mère.
Alors, c’est évidemment une légende.
Mais il y a une part de vérité derrière
cette légende : Rousseau était un enfant
très précoce.
C’est vrai qu’il a appris à lire très
tôt.
Ça s’explique par le fait qu’il est né
dans le milieu des artisans cultivés de Genève.
Ces artisans étaient instruits, curieux de
la politique et de la gestion de leur cité.
Ils lisaient des romans, mais aussi de la
vulgarisation scientifique, du droit et de
l’histoire.
Et puis bien sûr, les classiques, comme les
Vies parallèles de Plutarque, qui sont les
biographies des grands hommes de l’Antiquité
gréco-romaine
(le titre, « Vies parallèles », s’explique
par le fait que Plutarque raconte systématiquement
la vie d’un Grec, puis celle d’un Romain
qui lui ressemble pour comparer leurs destins
[ce sont donc des couples de biographies,
le plus célèbre étant le couple Alexandre
le Grand-César]).
Si Rousseau lit aussi tôt, c’est plus précisément
parce que sa mère était une femme cultivée
et une grande lectrice.
Elle est morte à la naissance de Rousseau,
mais elle a laissé beaucoup de livres que
son fils dévorera dans son enfance.
Et au départ, il ne lit pas tout seul.
Son père, qui était un de ces artisans cultivés
de Genève, lit avec lui le soir, parfois
toute la nuit.
C’est la seule école qu’a connue Rousseau.
Il est probablement le plus génial autodidacte
de l’histoire.
Il a appris à lire et il AIME lire
— donc il lira énormément, quand il aura
accès à une bibliothèque et qu’il aura
le temps.
Mais l’expérience DÉCISIVE dans la formation
de sa culture philosophique, c’est son travail
de ghostwriter au début de la trentaine.
Il travaille pour Madame Dupin, une riche
aristocrate et ardente féministe.
Elle a l’ambition d’écrire un grand livre
sur le rôle des femmes dans l’histoire.
C’est pour cela que Rousseau lit une centaine
de livres de d’histoire, de droit, de science
politique.
Donc pas des romans de gare.
Et attention, Rousseau ne se contente pas
de lire comme ça, parce que sa patronne,
elle veut des résultats !
Il fait ce que je ne cesse de recommander
sur cette chaîne et dans mes e-mails :
il lit LA PLUME À LA MAIN, c’est-à-dire
EN PRENANT DES NOTES !
Et BEAUCOUP DE NOTES !
Il abat donc un ÉNORME travail de lecture.
Il noircit des milliers de pages de notes
avec les meilleures idées, les meilleures
citations, des chronologies, etc.
Rousseau avait déjà beaucoup lu avant ce
travail
— mais APRÈS ce travail, il a passé un
cap.
Il a désormais la culture intellectuelle
d’un grand penseur.
Voici les toutes dernières lignes écrites
par Rousseau, quelques mois avant sa mort
:
« Aujourd’hui, il y a précisément cinquante
ans de ma première connaissance avec Mme
de Warens.
Elle avait vingt-huit ans alors, étant née
avec le siècle.
Je n’en avais pas encore dix-sept.
Ce premier moment décida de moi pour toute
ma vie, et produisit par un enchaînement
inévitable le destin du reste de mes jours.
»
Vieillard solitaire et malheureux, il repense
à Mme de Warens, qui lui avait dit :
« Pauvre petit, quand tu seras grand, tu
te souviendras de moi ».
Cette femme qui l’a recueilli à la fin
de l’adolescence a joué le rôle de la
mère qu’il n’a jamais eue
— il l’appelait d’ailleurs « Maman
».
Elle a tellement compté pour lui qu’il
l’a immortalisée dans ses fameuses Confessions.
Il en a même fait un mythe : le mythe de
« Maman ».
Une femme au grand cœur qui, telle une mère,
prend sous sa protection un pauvre jeune homme
qui ne demande qu’à aimer.
Mais la réalité derrière le mythe n’est
pas reluisante…
Bah oui, on ne dit pas du mal de sa mère
!
La première chose, c’est que Mme de Warens
ne recueille pas Rousseau parce qu’elle
a un grand cœur, mais parce qu’elle est
payée pour !
Elle est financée par le roi de Sardaigne
pour convertir des protestants au catholicisme.
Il en découle une autre réalité peu reluisante
:
si elle est payée pour convertir des protestants
au catholicisme, elle ne peut pas multiplier
les aventures.
Elle risquerait de créer un scandale, puis
de perdre son revenu.
Donc si elle a une relation avec Rousseau,
et s’il a l’impression qu’elle n’est
qu’à lui… c’est parce qu’elle n’a
pas le choix !
Garder un jeune homme à convertir auprès
de soi, c’est la manière la plus discrète
pour elle d’avoir un amant !
Rousseau est bien déçu quand il découvre
que Claude Anet, le jeune serviteur de Mme
de Warens, joue en réalité le même rôle
que lui auprès d’elle
— sa « Maman » a donc en réalité deux
amants qui vivent auprès d’elle…
Et puis Rousseau sera malheureux quand un
nouvel amant prendra sa place.
Autre réalité derrière le mythe de « Maman
» : elle est une escroc !
Elle a ruiné son mari et elle s’est enfuie
en emportant ce qu’elle pouvait emporter.
La ruine du mari est telle qu’il sera obligé
de se cacher en Angleterre.
L’amant qu’a remplacé Rousseau surveillait
les finances de Mme de Warens
— mais après son suicide (probablement
de jalousie), Mme de Warens dépensera n’importe
comment.
Elle multipliera les combines et les projets
foireux, si bien qu’elle finira sa vie dans
la misère
(Rousseau l’aidera à plusieurs reprises
alors qu’il a lui-même des moyens limités).
Enfin, dernière réalité peu reluisante
concernant « Maman » :
comme elle a un certain talent pour mentir
et pour cacher, l’argent que lui donne le
roi de Sardaigne ne rémunère pas seulement
ses efforts pour convertir des protestants…
Elle lui sert aussi — et c’est peut-être
en fait son véritable rôle —
elle est agent secret pour le roi de Sardaigne
!
Elle disparaît ponctuellement pour effectuer
des missions
(nous n’en savons rien puisque, par définition,
elle est agent SECRET).
Et il semble qu’elle ait même confié certaines
missions à Rousseau lui-même, ce qui veut
dire qu’il a une petite expérience d’espion
!
D’ailleurs, à l’époque, Chambéry — où
vit Rousseau avec Mme de Warens — Chambéry
est un nid d’espions parce que c’est un
carrefour stratégique en Europe, entre la
France, l'Italie et la Suisse.
Au début de la trentaine, Rousseau loge dans
un hôtel parisien.
À table, lors des repas, les hommes taquinent
la jeune lingère
— c’est-à-dire une servante qui s’occupe
du linge de l’hôtel —
les hommes attablés taquinent la jeune lingère
au point de lui faire venir les larmes aux
yeux.
Rousseau, qui est très sensible, prend sa
défense.
Ils se rapprochent.
La jeune lingère, qui s’appelle Thérèse,
devient son amante.
Et puis avec le temps, elle devient sa compagne.
Concrètement, elle est en même temps son
amante et sa gouvernante.
Elle s’occupe de tout dans son quotidien
: elle met de l’ordre, nettoie, cuisine,
etc.
Mais ce qui est très étonnant, c’est qu’elle
est infiniment moins intelligente que Rousseau.
Lui, c’est un génie autodidacte, un polymathe,
un intellectuel ultracultivé ;
elle, c’est une servante, je cite le biographe
« à la limite de la débilité ».
Elle sait à peine lire et écrire.
Elle est incapable de citer les mois de l’année
dans l’ordre.
Je cite encore le biographe : « Son esprit
est un désert ».
Le contraste entre elle et Rousseau est tel
que les amis du philosophe conspireront pour
qu’ils se séparent.
Ils échoueront, et Diderot en pleurera.
Pourquoi Rousseau fait-il de Thérèse sa
compagne ?
Il y a bien sûr le confort domestique : Thérèse
prend soin de lui.
Mais il y a une chose moins avouable qui fait
que Rousseau trouve vraiment son compte dans
cette relation.
Thérèse lui met des fessées !
Eh oui, Rousseau est masochiste !
Il date cette tendance d’un épisode de
son enfance que les Confessions ont rendu
célèbre :
une femme qui s’occupait de son éducation,
Mlle Lambercier, lui donne une fessée, et
Rousseau se rend compte qu’il en tire du
plaisir.
À la fessée suivante, c’est elle qui se
rend compte que quelque chose cloche — et
elle arrêtera de lui en donner.
Depuis, Rousseau cherchera des femmes pour
répéter cette épisode de son enfance.
À l’adolescence, il traîne au fond des
cours et dans les allées sombres, et au passage
des filles, il se déculotte devant elles
dans l’espoir que l’une d’entre elles
lui applique une délicieuse fessée !
Bien sûr, ça rend sa vie sentimentale compliquée.
Mais Thérèse, elle, accepte de faire ce
qu’aucune autre femme n’a accepté.
Oui, elle est presque débile — mais elle
donne de bonnes fessées.
Une fois que Rousseau est une star, naturellement,
tout le monde veut le voir.
Mais comme toutes les stars, il est très
peu disponible.
Mais vous pouvez faire une chose pour qu’il
accepte de vous rencontrer : lui donner de
la musique à copier.
À l’époque, les musiciens ne peuvent pas
photocopier ni imprimer leur partitions, donc
ils les font copier à la main.
Ça demande une grande précision, une connaissance
de la notation musicale et une écriture claire.
Rousseau a ses compétences.
Et en plus, il a le sens moral d’un artisan
— c’est-à-dire qu’il aime le travail
bien fait.
Il travaille un peu plus lentement que les
autres copistes, mais très soigneusement.
Ses copies sont impeccables.
Du coup son tarif est un plus élevé.
Sauf que beaucoup de clients n’en ont rien
à faire de leur commande !
Ils veulent simplement approcher le célèbre
écrivain !
Même les personnes les plus prestigieuses
doivent en passer par là.
Mais pourquoi Rousseau se fait-il chier à
copier de la musique ?
À l’époque, un écrivain aussi célèbre
que lui peut largement vivre de sa plume.
C’est vrai que les éditions pirates réduisent
considérablement les droits d’auteur
— mais en général, un auteur à succès
trouve un mécène qui le met à l’abri
du besoin.
Oui, mais voilà : en acceptant l’argent
d’autrui, on devient redevable — on n’est
plus libre.
Et ça, Rousseau le refuse absolument !
Une des valeurs les plus importantes pour
lui
— et peut-être même la valeur LA PLUS
IMPORTANTE — c’est l’indépendance.
Et l’indépendance garantit la liberté.
Rousseau protège tout d’abord sa liberté
intellectuelle.
« J’ai toujours senti, dit-il, que l’état
d’auteur n’était, ne pouvait être illustre
et respectable qu’autant qu’il n’était
pas un métier.
Il est trop difficile de penser noblement
quand on ne pense que pour vivre.
»
Mais il protège aussi sa liberté morale.
Rousseau a été domestique à plusieurs reprises
dans sa jeunesse, et il a terriblement souffert
dans cette condition.
C’est carrément un traumatisme.
Rousseau ne veut plus jamais avoir à obéir
à un quelconque supérieur.
Il ne veut plus jamais dépendre d’un autre
homme.
Cela le conduira à des refus qui paraîtront
choquants, et même égoïstes.
Par exemple, Louis XV veut le rencontrer après
avoir apprécié son opéra Le Devin du Village,
ce qui signifie que le roi veut lui donner
une pension.
Pour Rousseau, cette récompense représente
à la fois la fin de la pauvreté et le prestige
artistique.
Et pourtant il refuse !
Deux jours après le refus, Diderot va voir
Rousseau et l’engueule violemment.
Mais rien n’y fait : Rousseau veut rester
indépendant.
C’est si important pour lui que, dans la
foulée, il démissionne de l’emploi alimentaire
qu’il avait obtenu grâce à sa notoriété.
Il vivra donc exclusivement en copiant de
la musique.
Il sera pauvre, mais libre.
Et son amour de l’indépendance grandira
encore avec les années.
À partir de la cinquantaine, lorsque commenceront
ses ennuis avec les autorités et l’opinion
publique, Rousseau est si susceptible qu’il
refuse le moindre cadeau.
Une bouteille de vin, un bon plat…
il n’accepte rien !
Il gâche pas mal d’amitiés en soupçonnant
des proches de vouloir le corrompre.
Pardon pour l’interruption, mais j’ai
une question à vous poser :
Vous croyez VRAIMENT que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non — sinon on ne pourrait
pas parler de grand-chose.
Eh oui, il y a vingt-quatre heures dans une
journée, et il faut travailler, manger, dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale, ce
n’est PAS de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait, il n’y a pas qu’un seul
secret, il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes les plus cultivés,
les profs, et les intellectuels CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets, mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer RAPIDEMENT et FACILEMENT leur
culture générale, parce que leur rapport
au savoir A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur sur
n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire pour faire
preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets, inscrivez-vous
simplement soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de
la vidéo, soit en cliquant sur celui qui
est dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de 10 secondes, donc
faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud dans votre
boîte mail après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà, je vous ai dit ce que je voulais
vous dire.
Bonne vidéo !
Nous sommes en 1749 : Rousseau a donc 37 ans.
Son ami Diderot, un autre grand philosophe
des Lumières, le maître d’œuvre de la
fameuse Encyclopédie — Diderot est en prison
à Vincennes.
Les autorités l’accusent d’avoir critiqué
la religion officielle.
Comme Rousseau est pauvre et qu’à l’époque,
il n’y a pas le RER, c’est à pied qu’il
va voir Diderot à la prison de Vincennes
(à l’est de la capitale).
Cet été, il fait très chaud.
Le soleil tape.
Pour marcher moins vite et donc moins suer,
Rousseau emporte une revue qu’il lit sur
le chemin.
Il y trouve la question du concours de l’Académie
de Dijon :
« Si le rétablissement des sciences et des
arts a contribué à épurer les mœurs ».
Pour faire simple, c’est un peu un concours
de dissertation pour les intellectuels.
Et quand Rousseau lit le sujet de l’Académie
de Dijon — « Si le rétablissement des
sciences et des arts a contribué à épurer
les mœurs » — il a une révélation.
Il est en transe.
Toutes ses lectures, toutes ses réflexions
fusionnent en lui et suggèrent des images
pour répondre à la question de l’Académie.
Non seulement Rousseau gagne le concours,
mais il devient une star du jour au lendemain.
Pour l’expliquer avec une expression de
notre époque, son texte devient VIRAL.
Tout le monde en parle.
D’innombrables compte-rendus, commentaires,
ou réfutations sont publiées.
Le fond du discours de Rousseau est donc très
contesté.
Mais ce qui fait l’unanimité, c’est le
style de Rousseau.
Il écrit si bien, disent ses adversaires,
qu’il peut persuader le lecteur de n’importe
quoi.
Et effectivement, le style de Rousseau est
un des plus beaux de la langue française.
Ses idées, elles, ne sont pas nouvelles.
L’opposition entre la science et la vertu
est un débat classique.
Et Rousseau puise dans plein de références
connues.
Mais comme souvent dans l’histoire des idées,
on attribue leur paternité à celui qui a
le talent pour les populariser.
Mme de Staël, une des femmes de lettres françaises
les plus célèbres du XIXe siècle, dira
: « Rousseau n’a rien découvert, mais
il a tout enflammé ».
La notoriété qu’il gagne avec son Discours
sur les sciences et les arts est si grande
et si rapide qu’il fait beaucoup de jaloux.
Et parmi ceux qui connaissent les circonstances
de la rédaction du discours, certains posent
une question :
est-ce vraiment Rousseau le génie à l’origine
de ce succès intellectuel ?
Eh oui, parce que si Rousseau a découvert
le sujet du concours de l’Académie de Dijon
en allant voir Diderot, eh bien…
il lui en a parlé.
D’où la thèse de certains : le véritable
génie intellectuel derrière le Discours
sur les sciences et les arts, c’est Diderot.
Sans Diderot, pas de Rousseau.
Ça, c’est vrai : sans Diderot, pas de Rousseau.
Ils se rencontrent au tout début de la trentaine
à Paris (ils ont quasiment le même âge)
et c’est un coup de foudre intellectuel.
Ils passent beaucoup de temps ensemble.
Ils discutent tout le temps.
Ils jouent aux échecs.
Mais la vérité, c’est que Diderot parle
beaucoup plus — c’est un peu un monologue
à deux.
Diderot, qui est brillant — et objectivement
plus brillant que Rousseau —
Diderot est un peu son coach intellectuel.
Il l’aide à développer et clarifier ses
idées.
Il STIMULE donc intellectuellement Rousseau.
Mais est-ce vraiment Diderot qui lui donne
l’idée de répondre à la question de l’Académie
de Dijon en prenant le contrepied de l’opinion
commune,
c’est-à-dire en critiquant les sciences
et les arts ?
Non.
Rousseau avait bien compris que la plupart
des candidats allaient faire l’éloge des
sciences et des arts,
et donc qu’il était impossible de se distinguer
en prenant le même angle.
Diderot ne fait que CONFIRMER ce choix.
Mais c’est vrai qu’il a encouragé Rousseau.
Rousseau hésite à participer au concours
parce qu’il doute de ses capacités
— c’est ce qu’on appelle aujourd’hui
le « syndrome de l’imposteur ».
Mais Diderot l’encourage et le conseille.
Au début de la cinquantaine, Rousseau réside
à Môtiers, dans le canton de Neuchâtel
(au nord-ouest de la Suisse actuelle).
Un vendredi, c’est la foire de la ville.
Au milieu de la nuit, la maison de Rousseau
est bombardée d’une grêle de pierres.
Une des pierres casse les vitres de la cuisine
et roule jusqu’au pied du lit.
Elle fait presque deux kilos.
On n’est plus dans l’insulte : c’est
carrément un attentat.
Cette anecdote explique l’état d’esprit
de Rousseau à la fin de sa vie, à partir
de la cinquantaine (il est mort à 66 ans).
Oui, il est ultra susceptible, voire fou.
Il est ce qu’on appelle aujourd’hui « complotiste
», c’est-à-dire qu’il explique tout
ce qui lui arrive par un complot.
Mais mettez-vous à sa place : vous dormez
paisiblement dans votre lit, et des fous furieux
vous lancent des pierres de deux kilos qui
atterrisent au pied de votre lit !
Oui, Rousseau est complotiste.
Mais il n’est pas devenu complotiste en
passant ses nuits sur internet.
Il est complotiste parce qu’il est persécuté.
Les autorités de plusieurs gouvernements
veulent le mettre en prison, et des excités
passent près de l’assassiner.
Ses persécutions commencent quand il a 50
ans, avec la parution de l’Émile, son traité
d’éducation.
Ce livre crée le scandale pour ses propos
sur la religion.
Rousseau affirme que la religion est une affaire
de sentiment, que Dieu est dans la conscience,
dans le cœur de l’homme.
Du coup, tous les intermédiaires sont inutiles
pour être un véritable chrétien.
Rousseau discrédite totalement les institutions
religieuses.
Donc forcément, elles ne vont pas lui taper
dans la main.
Mais s’il n’y avait que ça !
Rousseau a aussi contre lui une partie des
philosophes.
Autrement dit, il s’est mis tout le monde
à dos : les partisans de la religion, et
les partisans de la raison !
Et il a notamment pour adversaire le plus
fameux partisan de la raison : Voltaire !
(D’ailleurs, j’ai déjà fait une vidéo
sur la vie de Voltaire, si ça vous intéresse.)
Le complotisme de Rousseau, c’est en partie
la faute de Voltaire.
Avant que Rousseau ne soit célèbre, et dans
les premiers temps de sa célébrité, leur
relation est plutôt bonne.
Comme beaucoup d’écrivains en devenir,
Rousseau est fan de Voltaire, qu’il lit
et qui l’inspire.
Ils collaborent même pour la réécriture
d’une comédie-ballet de Voltaire, La Princesse
de Navarre.
Ils n’ont pas les mêmes idées, mais ils
continuent d’échanger une fois que Rousseau
est un écrivain de premier plan.
Mais au bout d’un moment, Voltaire ne peut
plus tolérer le fait que Rousseau critique
la civilisation, en particulier le divertissement.
La dernière goutte, c’est lorsque Rousseau
prend position contre l’établissement des
théâtres à Genève dans sa fameuse Lettre
sur les spectacles.
Voltaire, qui est un grand auteur de théâtre,
fait bâtir au même moment un théâtre privé
dans sa propriété située à la frontière
de la Suisse.
À ses yeux, Rousseau fait alliance avec l’Église.
Or, l’ami de mon ennemi est mon ennemi.
Voltaire passe son temps à se battre contre
les superstitions religieuses.
Il ne peut pas accepter que Rousseau tire
contre le camp de la raison.
Et le problème, c’est que, quand on devient
l’ennemi de Voltaire, c’est vraiment la
guerre.
Voltaire ne recule devant rien pour gagner.
Et avec Rousseau, il va vraiment trop loin.
À plusieurs reprises, d’autres philosophes
le lui disent.
Il déterre des affaires dans le passé de
Rousseau et les rend publiques.
Il répand de fausses rumeurs.
Il écrit des pamphlets, de faux textes pour
discréditer Rousseau.
Et il semble qu’il ait même encouragé
les autorités à le persécuter, et qu’il
les y ait même aidées !
Comment s’étonner que Rousseau soit complotiste
?
Comment se sent-on quand on est persécuté
par l’intellectuel le plus influent d’Europe,
de surcroît milliardaire ?
Rousseau ne ferme pas l’œil.
Il passe ses nuits à imaginer les machinations
de Voltaire et des autres.
Il soupçonne tout le monde, y compris et
surtout ceux qui l’aident de bon cœur.
Par exemple, il attaque David Hume, un des
plus grands philosophes britanniques des Lumières
— il attaque David Hume alors même qu’il
l’a aidé, contre l’avis de ses amis,
à s’installer en Angleterre et qu’il
lui a même obtenu une pension royale.
Mais comme un chien battu, Rousseau n’arrive
plus à faire confiance.
Dans l’histoire de la littérature occidentale,
il n’est pas rare qu’un livre commence
à se vendre bien après sa publication, à
la fin de la vie de l’auteur, ou même après
sa mort.
Et inversement, un livre peut connaître un
immense succès à sa sortie, puis être oublié
par les générations de lecteurs suivantes.
Par exemple, vous savez qui a écrit le best-seller
français du XVIIIe siècle ?
Eh bien c’est Rousseau !
Eh oui, il n’est pas que philosophe !
Au milieu de la quarantaine, Rousseau a envie
d’écrire un roman.
C’est vrai qu’il a critiqué les romans
— mais il a vraiment envie d’en écrire
un, et puis il peut s’en servir pour faire
passer ses idées morales.
Ça donne Julie ou la Nouvelle Héloïse.
Ce roman épistolaire raconte l’histoire
d’amour d’une jeune aristocrate, Julie,
et de son précepteur St Preux.
Une fois séparés, Julie épouse un homme
bien plus âgé qu’elle, M. de Wolmar.
Puis elle choisit d’assumer ses devoirs
d’épouse et de mère malgré son amour
pour son ancien précepteur.
Ce roman n’est pas un succès, mais un véritable
triomphe.
Les exemplaires s’enlèvent comme des petits
pains et les éditions pirates se multiplient.
Certains libraires lancent même un business
de location du roman :
on paie à l’heure et il faut lire le roman
debout dans la boutique, pendant que d’autres
attendent leur tour.
L’histoire plaît à un public très large.
Au-delà des hommes de lettres et de la noblesse,
c’est toute la bourgeoisie francophone qui
admire Julie ou la Nouvelle Héloïse.
Une foule d’anonymes écrivent à Rousseau
pour lui dire ce qu’ils ont ressenti.
Les personnages du roman ont une énorme influence.
Inspirés par le bonheur familial décrit
par Rousseau, des pères de famille reprennent
goût à une vie qu’ils jugeaient monotone.
Instruits par l’exemple de St Preux, des
séducteurs décident de lever le pied.
Rousseau devient un peu le prophète des âmes
sensibles.
Admiratifs de son sentimentalisme, les auteurs
romantiques estimeront que leur rapport à
l’existence est déjà dans Julie ou la
Nouvelle Héloïse.
Mais ça, c’était il y a deux siècles.
Aujourd’hui, ce livre se vend peu et ne
fait pas partie des grands romans de la littérature
française.
J’ai compris pourquoi en le lisant il y
a une dizaine d’années :
c’est très long, répétitif, et on a l’impression
que Rousseau nous fait une leçon de morale.
Bien sûr, le style est magnifique.
Mais ce roman est éclipsé par les textes
philosophiques.
C’est dans ces textes que Rousseau exprime
son génie.
Chez M. de Girardin, le dernier hôte de Rousseau,
l'éducation des enfants est surprenante.
Eux qui sont des aristocrates, ils ont tout
le loisir de courir dans les champs et dans
les bois avec les enfants du village.
Leur père les contraint aussi à de longues
marches.
Pour déjeuner, ils doivent aller décrocher
la nourriture au sommet d’un poteau en bois
glissant
(ce qu’on appelle un « mât de cocagne
»).
Mais c’est quoi cette éducation ?
Eh bien c’est l’éducation de Rousseau
!
M. de Girardin est fan de l’Émile, le traité
d’éducation de Rousseau.
Et il n’est pas le seul.
Ce traité d’éducation a déjà une énorme
influence à l’époque de Rousseau.
Par exemple, des mères préfèrent allaiter
elles-mêmes leur nourrisson ; elles le baignent
dans l’eau froide.
Malheureusement, il y a parfois des drames
avec les disciples trop zèlés qui veulent
élever leurs nouveaux-nés à la dure.
L’éducation de l’Émile consiste à laisser
les enfants interagir avec la nature et apprendre
de leurs expériences plutôt que de les soumettre
à une discipline précoce.
À l’époque, cette philosophie enthousiasme
beaucoup de gens ;
mais beaucoup estiment aussi que c’est une
utopie imaginée par la personne la moins
légitime qui soit pour parler d’éducation.
Eh oui, parce que — vous le savez peut-être
— Rousseau a avoué dans ses Confessions
avoir abandonné les 5 enfants qu’il a eus
avec Thérèse.
Mais cet aveu est un mystère.
Selon certains, c’est un mensonge de Rousseau.
Il veut dissimuler son masochisme ou son impuissance.
Et puis ça rend aussi ses Confessions très
authentiques.
En effet, il est né avec une malformation
de la vessie et de l’urètre,
si bien qu’il a souvent envie d’uriner
— d’où, en partie, son amour des balades
en forêt —
et la malformation le rend peut-être aussi
impuissant.
Mais ce qui rend cette hypothèse peu crédible,
c’est qu’il était très courant d’abandonner
ses enfants à l’époque ;
que Rousseau, pauvre, non marié, et ambitieux,
avait toutes les raisons de le faire ;
qu’il avait déjà confessé l’abandon
à plusieurs amis ;
et enfin qu’il avait exprimé des remords
dans des lettres à Thérèse.
Mais en même temps, des personnes ont enquêté
pour retrouver les enfants ou les preuves
de l’abandon
— et elles n’ont rien retrouvé.
Alors, mensonge ou vérité ?
Personnellement, je ne sais pas, et je ne
penche même pas vers l’une ou l’autre
version.
Ce qui est certain, en revanche, c’est que
l’Émile a changé la vision de l’enfance
en Occident.
C’est en bonne partie grâce à Rousseau
que les parents pensent aujourd’hui que
leur enfant doit se développer naturellement.
Napoléon aurait dit devant la tombe de Rousseau
(avant qu’il n’entre au Panthéon) :
« C’est lui qui a préparé la Révolution
française ».
En effet, Rousseau est un des pères spirituels
de la Révolution française.
Ses idées y trouvent un écho considérable.
Chez les révolutionnaires français, Rousseau
passe pour le champion des droits de l’homme,
l’âme des nouvelles constitutions, à la
fois prophète et martyr.
Ce sont surtout les idées du Contrat social
— qui n’était pourtant pas le livre le
plus connu de Rousseau — ce sont les idées
de ce livre qui inspirent l’agitation politique
de l’époque.
Le pacte social, la souveraineté populaire,
la religion civile…
Rousseau est aussi le héros de grandes fêtes
officielles et patriotiques.
Lors de la fête du Triomphe du 14 juillet
1790, par exemple, on promène un buste en
pierre de Rousseau devant les ruines de la
Bastille.
Il n’est plus un philosophe, mais un mythe.
De 1790 à 1792, la nation lui voue un véritable
culte.
Plus personne n’est contre le penseur qui
s’était mis tout le monde à dos.
Mais en réalité, la « sanctification » de
Rousseau a commencé après sa mort.
Les voyageurs se rendent dans les lieux qu’il
a habités ;
ils touchent ses reliques (ses sabots, sa
tabatière) que des riches essaient d’arracher
à prix d’or.
Un jeune inconnu malade d’amour vient se
suicider dans la dernière demeure de Rousseau
en demandant à y être enterré.
Rousseau devient l’objet d’une véritable
industrie touristique.
Si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre.
Ce travail est vraiment formidable et passionnant.
»
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable.
J'étais un peu dubitatif étant donné le
prix initial mais je ne regrette pas, c'est
un vrai travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui ai une mémoire essentiellement auditive.
Le choix des thèmes et des chapitres est
pertinent et je trouve que tu as trouvé la
dose d'approfondissement parfaite ; à la
fois précis mais sans fioritures ! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme.
Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous bénéficiez
d'une garantie résultats : une fois que vous
aurez terminé le programme, je vous rembourserai
intégralement si vous estimez que vous n’avez
pas acquis une solide culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
Dans tous les cas, j’espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu.
Je suis Romain, et vous, vous étiez sur 1000
idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.